“I’ll eat my hat” is an utterance commonly
used when a person is absolutely certain that
something will not happen.
But where did this unusual phrase first originate
and have there ever been any recorded instances
of people actually eating their hats after
being proven wrong?
According to the venerable Oxford English
Dictionary, the earliest known example of
the phrase comes from the 1762 book Homer
Travestie, by Thomas Bridges.
The book is a parody of the more famous Iliad
and contains a line that reads:
For though we tumble down the wall, And fire
their rotten boats and all, I’ll eat my
hat, if Jove don’t drop us, Or play some
queer rogue’s trick to stop us.
While this is the first known example of the
phrase “I’ll eat my hat” as we’d understand
its meaning today, Bridges isn’t believed
to have coined the phrase as much as he streamlined
a now defunct utterance “I’ll eat Old
Rowley’s hat” that had essentially the
same meaning.
As for who “Old Rowley” was, this may
be referring to King Charles II who was called
such owing to his reputation with women combined
with the fact that “Old Rowley”
was the nickname of one of the King’s prized
stallions.
This is referenced, among other places, about
a century after Charles II’s death in The
Biographical History of England (1775):
In some of the State Poems, Charles II, is
ridiculed under the nick-name of Old Rowley,
which was an ill-favoured stallion kept in
the Mews, that was remarkable for getting
fine colts – Mrs. Holford, a young lady
much admired by Charles was sitting in her
apartment, and singing a satirical ballad
upon “Old Rowley the King,” when he knocked
at her door.
Upon her asking who was there? he with his
usual good humour replied, “Old Rowley himself,
madam.”
As for why the saying specifically mentioned
the king’s hat instead of, say, his shoes
or his underwear, this is speculated to be
due to the king’s fondness for fabulously
flamboyant hats which would be exceptionally
difficult, if not impossible, for a person
to eat.
(Incidentally, a similar foppish fashion trend
in the form of giant “macaroni” wigs is
also why Yankee Doodle stuck a feather in
his cap and called it “macaroni”.)
“I’ll eat my hat” gained widespread
acceptance about three-quarters of a century
later thanks to the 1837 novel written by
Charles Dickens, The Pickwick Papers, in which
we have the line: “If I knew as little of
life as that, I’d eat my hat and swallow
the buckle whole.”
This is uttered by a satellite character to
mock the main character who is contemplating
out loud about breaking a deal to avoid moving
into a sub-par house.
Given how long this expression has been around,
this may leave you wondering if anyone has
ever actually literally eaten their hat owing
to uttering the expression and subsequently
being proven wrong.
The answer is yes.
In fact, in the last few years alone there
are several documented instances of this occurring.
For example, in 2014 a user on Reddit predicted
that the value of one Bitcoin would never
again fall below $1000, adding that they’d
eat their hat if it ever did.
When the value of the currency did fall below
that mark, the user, amusingly identified
as “Hat Eater”, uploaded a video of themselves
eating an entire cotton beanie on a sandwich.
This is in keeping with the culture of Reddit
which particularly praises individuals who
follow through on such ridiculous boasts,
a more extreme example of which can be found
in the form of the guy who filmed himself
eating a bull penis after boasting that he’d
“eat a dick” if his post was liked enough…
(And if you’re curious, see: Why is “Dick”
Short for “Richard”?)
Then you have an Atlanta Falcons fan who filmed
himself eating one of his team’s hats after
declaring that the Falcons wouldn’t lose
to the Panthers in 2015, and if they did,
he’d eat his hat.
When they did lose, true to his word, he ate
the hat with a Wendy’s chicken sandwich.
Next up we have British politician Lord Paddy
Ashdown who publicly declared that he’d
eat his own hat if the exit polls for a British
election were correct.
When they were, Ashdown got out of the whole
thing while appearing to keep his word by
eating a chocolate cake shaped like a hat
during an interview.
During the same interview, another MP who’d
made a similar claim, only this time promising
to eat his kilt, ate a cake shaped like a
kilt- in both cases in true political form
the individuals actually broke their word
but attempted to make it appear as if they
did not.
Another example of following through on the
promise of eating a clothing item, though
this time not a hat, is that time famed director
Werner Herzog claimed that if Errol Morris
ever finished the film Heaven’s Gate (a
now legendary box office bomb) he’d eat
his shoes.
Herzog, true to his word, ate his shoes after
hiring a professional chef to prepare them
with garlic and various herbs at the premier
of the film.
You can see footage of this in the aptly titled
documentary, Werner Herzog Eats His Shoe.